hey David can someone who didn't win the
Iowa caucus still win the nomination
absolutely I've said from the start
especially because of the compression of
you've got Iowa was Monday February 3rd
we've then got New Hampshire we then
have Nevada then we have South Carolina
and then all within a month then it's
Super Tuesday March 3rd where you have a
whole bunch of Delegates the importance
of the first couple is mostly PR the PR
was a disaster because of the completely
failed way in which the DNC carried out
the caucus the failure of the app that
they developed I mean just an
embarrassing complete and total mess
which allowed multiple candidates to
essentially claim that they won it let
Donald Trump laugh at everybody on
Twitter which he did very very
successfully quite frankly it really
played into his hands but the 41
delegates from Iowa are not
make-or-break in any way other then
justifying from a PR standpoint that you
are viable right getting some delegates
in Iowa gets you past 0 and that's what
matters but you know Iowa's only
forty-one delegates New Hampshire is 24
delegates even smaller then Nevada is 36
delegates also smaller than Iowa but not
by much that the largest of the first
four primaries is South Carolina where
54 delegates are awarded but remember
with proportional allocation if you get
25% of the vote and someone else gets
20% of the vote you both end up with
almost the same number of delegates now
the thing I would be more concerned
about at this point the primaries are
going to happen and the delegate counts
are going to start to add up and only
after Super Tuesday are the paths going
to start to mathematically get harder
and harder after Super Tuesday we will
be able to make calculations like for
example based on all of the voting so
far in order for the third-place person
to win they would have to get you know
call it 50 percent of all remaining
delegates of making the numbers up and
then we would be able to start to say
well they've only gotten
12% of the delegates so far how likely
is it that from here on out they get
half of the remaining delegates and even
though they will stay in we will be able
to start mathematically closing the road
so to speak the path will begin to close
for a lot of different candidates for
now it's all wide open here's the really
important thing what I want to see is
what the DNC pulls oK we've been talking
about this for a while when it comes to
super-delegates when it comes to the
debate requirements at the beginning of
the week I told you the DNC is doing the
thing we thought they might do for a
long time which is they are changing the
debate qualification requirements in a
way that would make one really important
change it would allow Michael Bloomberg
to participate in the debates even
without accepting individual donors by
removing that as a requirement there
have started to be all sorts of
rumblings about you know is John Kerry
going to swoop in as Joe Biden fails I
don't think that's going to happen but
it's a conversation that was floating
around will the DNC put all of its
weight behind a different establishment
candidate we saw that the establishment
candidates by voting entrance polls in
the Iowa caucuses are Biden Budaj edge
and Chloe Shar will the DNC switch but
most importantly there are now a number
of reports including one we did on the
Tuesday bonus show saying that the NC
executives are talking about
can we put super-delegates back in the
first round of voting and to understand
the importance of that you have to
understand what happened back in 2016
back in 2016
super-delegates which are party insiders
and other sort of higher-ups designated
people in the D in the Democratic Party
they got to vote in addition to the
delegates that were won in primaries at
the Democratic National Convention so as
Bernie and Hillary were fighting it out
and they were close and they were one
when they we knew all along that because
all of these super-delegates were
pledged to Hillary Clinton that once you
get to that first vote at the convention
no matter what happens in the primaries
even if it's tight Hillary gets the
nomination because of the
super-delegates incredibly unfair and
undemocratic so since 2016 the
Democratic Party agreed not to allow
super-delegates to vote in the first
at the DNC so the idea is the delegates
vote in the first round at the
Democratic convention based on state
results if no one wins on the first
round then they do a second round where
super-delegates get to vote that was
what we knew up until Monday starting
Tuesday after the Iowa fiasco DNC
executives have started to have a
conversation about could we maybe go
back on that
could we maybe get the super-delegates
back into voting in the first round they
seem to recognize that it would enrage
millions of people and rightly so
because it's completely anti-democratic
but there is a conversation that is
taking place and I would be looking at
that more than who has the mathematical
path right now because Iowa New
Hampshire it's going to be wide open
going into Super Tuesday that that's for
sure let's see what the DNC plans to do